what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and welcome to my spoiler-filled
alden ring lore series for those of you
who don't know me i've been making from
software lore videos on my personal
channel for eight years now today let's
discuss the first major boss of elton
ring a demigod and lord who despite his
status was laughed at behind his back
but would yearn for approval today we'll
discuss godric the grafted and
stormville castle
to talk about godric we first need to
start with godfrey the first elden lord
while i do want to eventually do a full
lore video focusing on him for now just
a brief breakdown is what we need
godfrey fought for america's various
wars and causes to help spread the will
of the archery one of the first great
wars america and that urgery took on was
against the flame giants in ancient
times the giants were mortal enemies of
the archery
here it was godfrey who defeated them
and helped them emerge as victors for
the archery
hawk
brave
warriors hark my lord godfrey
we commend your deeds
guidance hath delivered ye through each
ordeal to the place ye stand
put the giants to the sword and confine
the flame atop the mount
let a new epoch begin
an epoch glistening with life
brandish the elden ring
for the age of the earth tree godfrey
was previously known as haralu and was a
great warrior who thirsted for battle
although it's unclear to me if it was
before or after fighting the war with
the giants he became godfrey while this
is speculation it could be the very
reason america utilized him and gave him
lordship in order to have a champion who
could win her battles
but when he decided to become elden lord
he needed a way to suppress his appetite
for war and that would come in the form
of the beast suraj
godfrey was a ferocious warrior when he
vowed to become a lord he took the beast
region suraj upon his back to suppress
the ceaseless lust for battle that raged
within
as such the lion would come to represent
godfrey the golden lineage and victories
in war from the golden beast crest
shield the beast depicted is suraj aged
counselor who guides the golden lineage
around this time when godfrey became
eldon lord he and america had children
together the children of america and
godfrey were known as the golden lineage
and due to their relation with america
were all demigods godric's great rune
tells us that the first demigods were
the elden lord godfrey and his offspring
the golden lineage which is how we know
that the golden lineage is specifically
people related to both america and
godfrey
meanwhile their demigod status is
specifically due to their blood
relationship with america
the demigods are each and all the direct
offspring
of queen america
so who do we know as part of the golden
lineage and therefore descendants of god
free america
well there's godwin who's often referred
to as godwin the golden with the golden
title indicating he's a part of the
golden lineage godwin was the first of
the demigods to die during the night of
the black knives but before that he was
best known for helping win another major
war with the urgery against the ancient
dragons
a great ancient dragon grand sax once
reigned calamity upon the royal capital
the only time a historical record that
lane del's walls have fallen
this marked the dawn of the war against
dragons
godwin the golden was a key part of the
capital's victory the routing of the
ancient dragons godwin the golden fought
to the last earning the friendship of
dread for the saks
long ago god when the golden defeated
the ancient dragon fortisacks and
befriended his fallen foe an event that
gave rise to the ancient dragon cult in
the capital
so thanks to god when the golden dragons
would become accepted in the capital the
worship of the ancient dragons does not
conflict with belief in the archery
after all this seal and lightning itself
are both imbued with gold
in fact dragons became rather mythicized
characters would go out of their way to
attack dragons eat their dragon hearts
and perform dragon communion in order to
try and become a dragon the ancient
dragons who ruled before the prehistoric
era of the archery would protect their
lord as a wall of living rock and so it
is that the shape of the dragon has
become symbolic of all manner of
protections
all of this is to say thanks to god when
the golden dragons became rather
accepted which i'm bringing up as it
will eventually come up with godric
so we know that godfrey america had
godwin in the golden lineage who was
both successful and revered but there
were two more who would be the exact
opposite moog and murgat morgoth's great
rune tells us that the omen king was
born of the golden lineage and that he
was indeed the lord of landel
meanwhile according to moog's great rune
logan morgat are twin brothers and their
great runes are naturally similar
mog and morgot were born omen who were
considered graceless and viewed as
impure but that is another giant can of
worms that i'll get to in a future video
next up is godfrey the grafted which i
don't know if that's the pronunciation
by the way we really don't know much at
all about god freud other than that
according to ancient dragon knight
kristoff's ashes during another war
considered the first defense of lane del
the ancient dragon knight kristoff
captured godfrey and he's now imprisoned
in a golden lineage ever jail it does
raise the question of when he did his
grafting and who else outside of godfrey
and godric performed the act
finally we have godric godric wasn't
necessarily godfrey america's son in
fact he probably wasn't the demigods are
each and all the direct offspring
of queen america
godric the graft it was but a distant
relation
the runt of the litter
his divine blood
solely diluted because the demigods are
all direct offspring of queen america
that would simply mean that they're
blood relation and not related through
marriage however as enya notes godric's
divine blood is sorely diluted which
would indicate that he could be a
grandchild or great-great-grandchild or
so on it could be that his father was
godfrey whose father was godwin whose
father was godfrey we simply don't know
to my best guess and this is speculation
godwin was likely the eldest son of
godfrey and first in line to the throne
hence why he was targeted by ronnie
during the night of the black knives
godfrey was likely godwin's son as the
name would be a way to honor his father
meanwhile godric could be god for his
child due to the resemblance and how
diluted his blood is supposed to be or a
less powerful twin brother of god freud
as they look so similar this is purely
my own speculation though so take it as
that as twins are such a major theme in
the game with moog slash morgot darion
slash devin and melania slash mikola it
wouldn't surprise me if godric and god
freud were in fact twins
but either way he was of royal blood and
is indeed of the golden lineage as such
godric grew up in lane del the royal
capital godric harbored a huge amount of
pride from his golden lineage
i command thee
i
am the lord of all that is golden
while he was the runt of the litter he
was still a lord and demigod so he did
have soldiers under his command while
his foot soldiers wore standard gear his
soldiers wore a tree and beast surcoat
which depicts the distant archery and
the beast regent and emblem of the
golden lineage both are symbols of glory
now past the beast being a reference to
godfrey's suraj meanwhile his knights
wore knight armor which has its left
breast emblazoned with a two-headed war
axe an emblem of the golden lineage this
two-headed war axe would be either the
axe of godric which was a great axe
wielded by godric the grafted the golden
battle axe is emblazoned with the figure
of a beast representing the strength of
god free first elden lord and patriarch
of the golden lineage or the acts of
godfrey which was originally a
two-headed war axe but it was broken in
a battle fought as leader of the tarnish
during the long march
when we find godric later on in
stormville many things around him
reference the archery the commoners who
he rules over like a stock where
commoners garb that notably has a board
hung from the neck depicting a sprawling
tree its roots and branches forming two
holes this is a self-imposed shackle a
voluntary display of allegiance to the
archery that increases faith
meanwhile the stormville courtyard is
adorned with statues that have more
archery symbolism on all of them the
statues found here somewhat resemble the
lanedale knights in the giant earth tree
crest at the top to me this looks like
the same symbol and according to the
lane dell night helm the golden canopy
represents the honor of standing among
the tree's defenders so all of that said
regardless of what would happen to
godric he always maintained his own
sense of loyalty to the archery and
likely more so the sense of power and
pride it afforded him as he was pretty
looked down upon
so that said this is going to be a bit
of speculation territory but i think
that godric likely had a bit of an
inferiority complex after all enya
herself refers to him as the runt of the
litter i want to look at a line from
gatekeeper gestak who served under
godric
what a pathetic excuse for a lord you
were
craven to the bone
pushing me about like that pushing
around people weaker than you could be
associated with someone who has an
inferiority complex and wants to feel
strong
and after all that crafting
where
you filthy slug
in fact grafting overall is looked down
upon in the world of alden ring which
makes sense
how utterly repellent this is
this grafting of godric's ill befits a
lord
he's tainted the very winds in fact
according to godric's very own
remembrance of the grafted a feeble man
sought power through the grotesque act
of grafting and from the marred leather
shield leather shield of stormville
soldiers much like the castle it is
marred by modeling and thorns some say
it is the curse of grafting which causes
such affliction while others talk of its
roots being something altogether more
sinister hidden deep within the castle
the point in this case is that grafting
is considered to be a disgusting and
grotesque act which would be similar to
why omen misbegotten and demi humans are
considered in pure because they aren't
one race or one thing from the crucible
not talisman a talisman fashioned from a
bony knot that embodies the aspect of
various creatures said to have grown on
the human body long ago a vestige of the
crucible of primordial life born
partially of devolution it was
considered a signifier the divine in
ancient times but is now increasingly
disdained as an impurity as civilization
has advanced a similar description comes
from the crucible feather talisman and
crucible scale talisman the more pure
you are
the better that's why some view mikola's
unalloyed gold as being the best analog
simply means pure and untainted so it's
pure gold thus in this world is viewed
as being better mykola is a little more
complex and that this likely has to do
with being free of meddling from the
outer gods and he helped those who were
downtrodden but the general theme we see
related to omen etc is that pure things
are good
but all of the grafting godric would do
was to try and get a feeling of power so
he could measure up to his ancestors who
he felt like he wasn't good enough for
look at this line from godric when he
graphs himself with a dragon
meanwhile after defeating the tarnished
in phase two of his boss fight he says
so now that we have a feel for his
character let's talk about the
shattering
once the alden ring was shattered a war
for control over the alden ring and lane
dell the royal capital ensued while
godric managed to nab himself a great
rune the anchor ring in the center of
the elder ring he ended up fleeing the
capital for stormville he took a
mimikvale with him so he could disguise
himself as one of the women fleeing and
leave with them when godric was hounded
from lane del the royal capital this was
one of a multitude of treasures he took
with him also known as america's
mischief first he hid himself amongst
the women folk to flee the capital then
hid from radon in that castle i think he
was likely hounded from the capitol by
morgat who used the opportunity to seize
power in the capital to defend the
urgery and golden order and defended
against those who he viewed as traitors
ah
godric the golden willful traitors
all
thy kind are all of a peace
pillagers
emboldened by the flame of ambition
looking back at the intro cutscene to
elden ring we actually see morgot
stabbing radon likely in a battle for
control over lane dell that morgott
would win it was probably around this
time that godfrey was captured by the
ancient dragonite kristoff who i would
guess was working in league with morgot
and therefore gained the honor of urgery
burial through morgot
so godric fled the stormville using the
mimikvale stormville which he probably
viewed himself as having a claim over
and had no residing lord before being
cast away godfrey went on a march south
of lane del conquering land in the name
of the golden order and teachings of
america we can track this progress by
looking at the church's america the
first church america is in the
mountaintops of the giants as their
teachings spread we see them get further
and further away all the way south to
the weeping peninsula where we find the
fourth church america godfrey defeated
and conquered castle mourne taking
control of it the siege of castle mourne
a lone hero fights for his vengeance
only to fall at the hand of lord godfrey
godfrey went all the way into caleb
before his campaign ended lord godfrey
at last at the end of his campaign his
golden armies unvanquished and unbowed
yet finds grace lost tattered and faded
and of course on the way south would be
stormville castle which was ruled by the
stormhawk king according to the elden
lord armor set the age of the archery
began amongst conflict when godfrey was
lord of the battlefield he led the war
against the giants faced the stormlord
alone according to the warhawk ashes
with this lord vanquished and his wings
wounded the hawk perished as it solemnly
gazed at his former home the storm is a
warhawks cradle and from stormhawk dean
spirit of a fierce hawk that faithfully
rendered lifelong service to the old
king of stormville long ago when the
true storm raged we also find the
stormhawk king who is a hawk revered by
all others as sovereign back in the days
when stormville's winds still raged like
no other this ancient monarch is proud
however refusing to answer anyone's
summons
so it's very possible that the stormlord
who godfrey defeated was the stormhawk
king
that said the storm of alden ring can
also refer to pharaoh missoula with the
dragons of former missoula being a major
enemy of the archery so that item
description could be referring to that
the part that i find particularly
interesting is that the stormhawk king
answers to nephili lou
in this ash
i can smell the ancient storm
it reminds me of my first talk
in fact giving her the stormhawk king
ashes leads to her becoming the master
of stormville this land is much like the
one from which i hail
i will call upon the storm
to drive away the foulness that has
settled on the winds
nathalie lou by her name is heralu's
direct descendant likely born after he
was banished from the lands between and
discarded his mantle as godfrey so it's
likely that godfrey defeated the
stormhawk king and gained its allegiance
through power and gained ownership over
stormfield castle then he eventually
left the lands between leaving
stormville castle leaderless
according to the banished knight engvall
ashes angval was one of the two knights
dubbed the wings of the storm despite
his banishment he rejected the
invitation of the grace given lord
instead keeping watch over a masterless
castle for many years gaining renown as
a hero of the fringes
which would further indicate that
perhaps hurrah lose slash godfrey was
the former master of stormville and his
leaving left it masterless it's worth
noting that the other wing of the storm
that banished night oleg instead took
the sight of murgat after his banishment
he attracted the notice of the grace
given lord and later having slayed a
hundred traitors as the lord's hand oleg
earned the hero's honor of urgery burial
we know thanks to sir gideon off near
that the grace given lord refers to
morgot moore got the grace given veiled
monarch and lord of lane dell
while i'm not certain if haralu or
godfrey ever truly ruled over stormville
either way i think this castle was
essentially owned by the golden lineage
even if it didn't have a residing master
which is all to say it would make sense
that this would be where godric would
head to after running away from lane
dell he'd already have subjects loyal to
him at stormville and there was no other
master leading the castle godric set up
his subjects as stormville took the
castle as his own and even had a beast
there resembling suraj the soldiers who
served godric the grafted are what
remains of the army that fled the royal
capital of the urgery i don't know the
exact timeline of this but it's possible
that this is the point godric began
grafting himself we see a main room in
stormville set up for grafting all in
view of a picture of godfrey then he
insulted melania lost to her in battle
only to lick her boots rather than die
like a man
i see no shame the big girl's blouse
after godric fled to stormville melania
decided to take on radon and march south
all the way from the halek tree past
leonia and towards radon here she
entered a conflict with godric who
surprisingly decided to take her on as i
mentioned it's possible he'd started
grafting himself at this point and
thought he was far more powerful than he
actually was that said i don't know the
exact point he started grafting godric
the golden humiliated having tasted
defeat by the blade of nicola now on his
knees begging for mercy while godric may
have humiliated himself
he survived and thanks to him failing to
stop melania in spectacular fashion
melania was able to continue her march
to radon where she and radom would end
up essentially destroying each other in
a stalemate battle melania was dragged
all the way back to the haley tree to
recover while radon was left insane with
scarlet rot eating him away
so after the battle godrick used the
opportunity to expand his influence he
set up edgar and castle mourn which
godfrey had previously won in battle i'm
edgar
warden of this castle as ordained by
lord godric himself
but you can see how things have turned
out
the menials have all rebelled
they gave me good service also i thought
but it seems it was all an act
meanwhile it seems he had his knights
kick someone who wasn't his loyal
kenneth height out of his fort young
tarnished
i would have a boon of you
i want you to take back my fort
it lies to the south beyond the mist
wood
a knight commander from stormville took
it a fool and plumbed to boot
simply obsessed with blood of course a
knight commander of stormville would be
someone acting in the service of godric
gadger set up his new home base here in
limgrave setting up various defensive
positions he hires or forces a number of
exiled soldiers to man his castle having
them defend the front gate with
ballistas walk through the gate and
you'll witness this in action he claims
the storm gate just outside of
stormville castle as his own and drapes
his banners along it additionally he
maintains the gatefront ruins sending
his soldiers there to defend and watch
for any incoming enemies on the way from
the stranded graveyard and first steps
towards the gatefront ruins and
stormville castle various people have
been crucified in the exact same manner
as america's holy image while there
isn't any direct proof that this was by
godric's hand i think it's pretty likely
this was godric sending a message
at some point around here godric began
obsessively grafting himself trying to
become stronger
i would take great care to avoid
godric's tarnished hunts where i in your
shoes that depraved lotter obsessed with
sacrificing tarnished like you for the
sake of grafting this place is bristling
with tarnish hunters you know
they sacrifice our kind
for grafting not exactly a place i'd
stroll into without a purpose in mind
but he didn't only seem to graft himself
in stormville castle in the grafting
grounds and near piles of bodies godric
took for grafting we find a grafted
scion everyone's
been grafted
everyone who came with me
they crossed the sea for me they fought
for me
only to have their arms taken
their legs taken even their heads
taken
taken and stuck
to the spider
did you know
if you're grafted by the spider
you become a chrysolid
it's quite the lark when you think about
it while godfrey is also grafted i think
it's likely the grafted silence are a
result of godric so where do we find
grafted scions we find two of them in
the fringe folk hero's grave guarding in
her tree's favor we find one disguised
as a giant crayfish in lyria we find one
on mount gelmere near the 9th mount
gelmir campsite and we find one at the
very beginning of the game at the chapel
of anticipation this grafted scion uses
and drops a golden beast crest shield
and an ornamental stray sword the golden
beast crest shield is a shield of dull
gold with a beast engraved at his crest
the beast depicted the suraj aged
castler who guides the golden lineage
meanwhile the ornamental stray sword is
a slender stray sword patterned after an
antique ornament after falling from
grace the dregs of the golden lineage
stop power and purpose in the past
both of these items are directly related
to godric again making me think it's
godric creating these grafted scions at
stormville castle and sending them out
to do his bidding most importantly here
is the one at the church of anticipation
godric and the other demigods are well
aware of the tarnish being brought back
to kill them and become elton lord so it
seems godrick created this grafted scion
and he put it here at the chapel of
anticipation specifically to stop
tarnish from ever even being able to
attempt to fight him and before they and
their maiden could use runes for power
to grow and stream
challenge godric the grafted lord of
stormvale to acquire a great room
decrepit he may be
but a demigod he remains and of course
an inheritor
of a great rune
worse yet
i hear old godricks acquired a ferocious
new toy to graft
so
prepare for the worst
as the ornamental stray sword tells us
after falling from grace the dregs of
the golden lineage saw power and purpose
in the past
recall that dragons are actually looked
at pretty fondly in present times within
the elden ring as i mentioned at the
beginning of the video godric also
thinking of dragons in a positive way
decides to also graft a dragon onto
himself
mighty dragon
dirty true born air
lend me thy strength o kindred
deliver me unto
greater heights
as far as being a true born heir this is
likely due to the fact that dragons
were elden lord before godfrey ever was
godfrey was only the first elden lord of
the archery
the dragonlord whose seat lies at the
heart of the storm beyond time is said
to have been elden lord in the age
before the archery once his god was fled
the lord continued to await its return
so perhaps godric knows this history as
he is a
demigod me thy strength
[Applause]
[Music]
in the end all godric wanted was to
return to this home in lane dell
i am the lord
of all
[Applause]
according to the gilded great shield
it's a shield carried by knights loyalty
godric the red tinge and the gold coat
mirrors the primordial matter that
became the er tree the color of homeward
yearning
that wraps up this lore video on godric
the grafted and stormville castle i
honestly didn't expect it to be this
long when i first started writing it but
it just goes to show how absolutely
dense and packed the lore of elden ring
is one major thing i didn't touch on was
godwin's image being in stormville
castle i want to save that for a
dedicated video on godwin of course as
always if there's anything i presented
you disagree with or you have other
theories i'd love to hear them i always
encourage people to seek out other lore
videos because there's things i might
have missed and other theories that
might seem more viable it's all a
discussion and this is that fun phase
where we're all figuring it out together
if you enjoyed this i'd appreciate if
you let me know and give a like and
subscribe it really means a lot to me i
intend to make many more videos and i
hope to make this a weekly lore series
if there are any comments that help give
me insight i wasn't able to find i'll
always give credit to you and i'll see
you guys next time peace